en ile de france environ 110 personnes
sont admises chaque jour en réanimation
selon santé publique france le nombre de
patients lourdement atteints s'élève
désormais à 1152 contre 925 la semaine
dernière une dégradation de la situation
qui inquiète valérie pécresse
la présidente de la région à ce lundi
ouvert la porte
or au confinement l'île de france est
clairement en sursis car le variant
angles est majoritaire n'est pas
seulement plus contagieux il est aussi
plus mortel et nos capacités de
réanimation sont saturés
c'est au gouvernement de décider mais
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus rien exclure
et en responsabilité si les mesures sont
justifiées
si elles sont proportionnées et
accompagner je ne m'y opposerais pas la
semaine dernière l'agencé régionale de
santé d'ile-de-france avait donné
l'ordre ferme aux hôpitaux et cliniques
de déprogrammer 40% de leurs activités
médicales et chirurgicales pour faire
face aux tensions hospitalières et des
transferts de patients vers des régions
moins touchées ont aussi commencé ce
week end
mais pour le président de la commission
médicale de l'assistance publique
hôpitaux de paris rémy salomon ce n'est
pas suffisant les transferts de malades
ne sont qu'une soupape de soulagement et
si la situation n'est pas encore hors de
contrôle
elle va l'être j'entends beaucoup dire
qu'une semaine son confinement est une
semaine gagner je n'ai pas la même
analyse pour moi c'est une semaine
perdue si jean castex n'a dimanche pas
exclu la piste dure confinement mais a
rappelé qu'il souhaitait pour le moment
l'éviter contenu les conséquences qu'il
pourrait avoir sur la population des
voix de la majorité commencent à se
délier
à l'image des aurore bergé la députée
lrm à ce lundi évoqué le risque d'un
confinement strict je ne crois pas à ce
débat de savoir s'il faut re confiné où
une partie de la semaine ou le week end
s'il fort confiné je crains que ce soit
un confinement strict auquel on doive se
préparer avec déjà 3 191 cas pour 100000
habitants jeudi
l'ile-de-france frisé avec le seuil des
400 cas fixé par jean castex pour mettre
en place des mesures similaires
à celle appliquée au pas de calais dans
les alpes maritimes alors qu'un conseil
de défense sanitaire est prévue mercredi
emmanuel macron a déclaré ce lundi qu'il
y aurait sans doute de nouvelles
décisions dans les jours à venir